hey guys it's karen here and something
has always kind of bothered me
you don't have on like shampoo bottles
where it says like volumizing
or sleeping shine or some other sort of
weird promise what i never understood is
why you have to
pick one of those things why wouldn't
they just put all of those things in one
shampoo bottle so i can have volumized
and sleek hair
it's not fair and today i figured that i
would solve that what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna go out and i'm gonna buy
a hundred shampoos yeah it seems like
overkill and that's because it is
then i'm going to mix them all together
and create
a perfect amazing awesome shampoo that
will surely either
make my hair fall out or make it amazing
so i think i'm probably gonna need some
help on this one unfortunately
and i just need to find someone
who'd be willing to help me connie
please help me
so guys here we have a hundred shampoos
each of them claiming different things
it was insane
to look for all of them but they are all
here now so the game plan
is is that we want equal amounts of each
of these guys into here so that's not
one overpowering thing
so i'm going to take a teaspoon of each
of them how much is 100 teaspoons
is that don't make me do math um
i'm sure this bowl will be fine this
one's
totally twisted by herbal essence
so it's for um curls and i don't have
curls but i did figure
that maybe if i got myself some curl
shampoo
that then maybe they'd appear because
that's how this works right
this is all very scientific what we're
doing our hair
is kind of like i'd say we have a lot of
flyaways
it's very straight and kind of flat i
hope
that through this experiment we get some
a little bit of volume
and maybe some smoothing action yeah i
could see that couldn't help but pick up
one kid's shampoo and we chose frozen
because
scissors wow hold up you guys have to
see this one good
oh that one's so pretty
this one is called intensity it smell
like
oh it just shot at me
we did grab a couple of mid ones because
we want to know what they've been
holding out on us all these years i'm
actually doing this much cleaner
than i thought i would be doing i mean i
guess all this is pretty clean this is
good clean fun
with that what are we at 50.
halfway through all right we've got a
very special one for number 51
got some old spice and it promises
swagger this is starting to get a smell
that can only be described as if an
entire flower shop
caught on fire what if this just this
whole bowl like started smoking
just self-destruction
okay i think we only have 10 left
home stretch let's do it
and with that we are done
[Laughter]
oh look at it oh it's so pretty it's so
much prettier than i thought it would be
no it's turning like a snot green
yeah here she is are a hundred
shampoos all mixed together in one
bottle is it eating through yet
we've gotta actually test this guy to
see if all of the claims come together
oh
we you're the only one putting that on
your head
i'm going to put this on my hair and you
use our regular shampoo okay
and then we'll compare our hair and see
if it looks better or anything
okay do you think all my hair will fall
out i think it's a 50-50 chance
so here's my hair it is air dried
overnight like i normally do
the shampoo perform pretty normally i am
going to
style it i'm sure there was something in
there that's heat activated
and then we'll compare it to connie and
see if we can see any results
okay guys so our hair is all style now
we use
um our normal just hot tools and in the
twists
of all twists even though connie only
used one product in her hair
it somehow looks so much more volumized
and beautiful
do a twirl looks great
i'm guessing that all those products
mixed together just kind of added weight
to my hair making it look heavy and
a tad poofy but at least my hair is
clean and now i know companies aren't
scamming me out of the perfect
everything included shampoo maybe man is
just not meant to mix a hundred shampoos
and have the perfect one
or maybe if we just need to mix a
hundred conditioners
no that is not it
you